delighted and I fell
Walker junior lecturer in International
Studies indeed I think strobe hat now
will have the distinction as the only
person is actually giving this lecture
twice he gave it once before way back in
the last century the Honorable George
Herbert Walker the third former the US
ambassador to Hungary established this
lecture series in 1986 in memory of his
father that a distinguished graduate of
the Yale class of 1927 strobe talbott
assumed the presidency of the Brookings
Institution in July of 2002 after a
career in journalism government and the
Academy his immediate previous post was
right here in New Haven where he was the
founding director of the Yale Center for
the Study of globalization he served in
the State Department from nineteen
ninety three to two thousand one first
as ambassador at large and special
adviser to the Secretary of State Warren
Christopher for the new independent
states of the former Soviet Union and
then as deputy secretary of state for
seven years prior to government service
as many people know strobe Talbott was
with Time magazine for 21 years as a
reporter he covered Eastern Europe the
State Department and the White House and
then he served as as Times Washington
bureau chief and editor-at-large and
foreign affairs columnist he's authored
many books including engaging India
diplomacy democracy and the bomb the
master of the game deadly gambits Reagan
and the Russians and end game as well as
several others strobe Talbot has been a
fellow of the Yale Corporation a trustee
of the hotchkiss school and the Carnegie
Endowment for international peace and a
director of the Council on Foreign
Relations the North American executive
committee of the Trilateral Commission
and the American Association of Rhodes
Scholars he's currently a member of the
participating faculty of the World
Economic
warm and a member of the Aspen Strategy
Group strobe is an alumnus of Yale be a
1968 ma honors honorable MA in 1976 and
Oxford where he got his em lit in 71
that all bought has honorary degrees
from the Monterey Institute Trinity
College Georgetown and Fairfield
University and he's been awarded state
orders by the presence of estonia
germany lithuania poland in by the king
of Sweden the title that drove his tone
has chosen for his lecture today is
America and the world restoring a
damaged foreign policy and I'm pleased
to introduce to you mr. strobe Talbot
thanks Ian very much listening to all
that makes me want to kind of take a nap
I'd actually forgotten a couple of those
things the only thing that you forgot to
mention is that I am a friend and
colleague and a protege of Professor Ian
Shapiro and that counts for a lot
logically ian has been part of my life
since just about the time I came up here
to spend some time working on this
campus i'll remember always remember the
working lunch that we had at the union
league club when you told me a little
bit about how the university works and
i've had the pleasure of watching over
the last several years and how you have
not only led the political science
department but also done such terrific
things with the work that goes on in
this in this building and what I still
think of was YC is but I will learn to
call the Macmillan center there are a
lot of friends and colleagues here in
the room and I won't take a lot of time
to acknowledge them but I do want to say
particularly what a pleasure it is to
have
Nyan john de and his wife get Anjali
here they are family as well as friends
and one of the events that allowed me to
they allowed me to participate in
earlier in the day was a celebration up
at bet's house of the 100 millionth hit
on the Yale global website that's a
that's an inadequate numerical
indication of how extraordinarily
successful the best online magazine on
the subject of globalization in the
world is and how proud all this
connected with Yale should be that it's
here and I might add it's a pleasure to
see Gus ranis with whom I worked very
closely when I was up here a number of
years ago I always relish the chance to
come back to mother Yale and she is a
hospitable and forgiving mother indeed
and I as Ian mentioned had an
opportunity to give this lecture back in
nineteen ninety I and I was then a
reporter and columnist for Time magazine
and the lecture gave me a chance to talk
a little bit about the foreign policy of
an American president who was very
closely associated with the the donor
and the honoree of this lecture series
george herbert walker bush and so here i
am again 17 years later not just under
the same auspices but at a time when the
chief executive of our country is once
again a son of yale and indeed a father
of a daughter of yale and who has two
thirds of george herbert walker name in
his own
therefore it seems to be fitting that in
order to get some discussion started
with all of you I might offer a few
thoughts about the comparison between
these two presidents father and son only
the second time in the history of our
country that we have had a father and a
son in the White House I would contend
and that what is most remarkable about
the comparison between what we in
Washington call Bush 41 and Bush 43 and
I guess down at the Alumni Office on
York Street they'd probably call Bush 45
and Bush 68 is not what they have in
common but what makes them so very
different and that's what I'm going to
talk about for the next few minutes and
setting aside the fact that they are
father and son I don't think there has
ever been a pair president certainly not
two presidents so closely in office in
terms of time who have been so different
in their view of the world so different
in their view of America's role in the
world so different in the effect that
they have had on the world's view of
America and so different in the legacy
and the challenges that they will have
left to their successors as these two
presidents both named bush now I'll
start by defining what I see as the
essential difference between the two
presidents bush then I'll try to explain
that difference why I think it came
about and a little bit about its
implications for the future including
the next president of the United States
and then I hope you'll tell me what you
think
and we'll have a bit of a discussion as
long as ian is prepared to let the
program go our first president Bush the
41st president of the United States was
a paragon of what I would call
traditional American internationalism
and I'm a kind of traditional guy myself
and so I mean that very much as a
compliment he relied and indeed helped
bring about a world order that was
us-led rule-based and architectural and
I think I should explain what those last
two terms in particular mean when I say
rule bit rule-based I mean an
international system of norms some
codified in treaties and an
international law that apply to all
countries although there's obviously
always going to be plenty of room for
disagreement over what those rules mean
and how they should be applied when I
talk about an architectural
international system I mean one that is
based largely on structures and in
particular those structures for which
the United States was in the period
immediately after World War two the
master builder the general contractor
and the principal financier I'm thinking
here particularly about the United
Nations itself the Bretton Woods
institutions IMF in the World Bank North
Atlantic Treaty Organization and the
European Union now the european union of
course does not have the United States
among its members but it's worth
remembering that the EU came into
existence largely at American prodding
and under an American security umbrella
the first president Bush exemplified
this rule-based architectural approach
and he applied it to the most important
and difficult challenge that he faced
while he was in the wine
which was helping manage the collapse of
the Soviet Union and the Warsaw Pact and
the end of the Cold War and that
explains the title of the lecture that I
gave here back in nineteen ninety which
was bush and Gorbachev to the great
benefit of humanity that President Bush
served as a Kong clear-minded very
patient round control officer for
Gorbachev as that last Soviet president
piloted the craft of the Soviet empire
in for a not a soft landing and at least
not a crash landing on the ash heap of
history and in playing that role as
Gorbachev's ground control officer
President Bush worked hard to strengthen
international institutions and then to
integrate into those institutions first
Gorbachev Soviet Union and then Boris
yelstin yeltsin's post-soviet Russia in
the fall of nineteen ninety which was
just about the time I was here to give
the Walker lecture President George
Herbert Walker Bush introduced into the
vocabulary of the international system
and u.s. foreign policy the phrase new
world order and I think it's quite
significant the President Bush made that
statement introduced that concept from
the podium of the General Assembly of
the United Nations in Turtle Bay and he
did so in the context of his appeal for
international support as a massive
american-led coalition was positioning
itself in the Saudi desert for an
invasion of Iraq that would have the
authorization of the Security Council
the first Gulf War was a masterpiece of
us-led multilateral diplomacy combined
with the us-led application of
multilateral
Operation Desert Storm was not just well
conceived it was well executed in that
it accomplished its task which was the
expulsion of Saddam Hussein's occupation
forces from Kuwait let's just ponder for
a moment the summary of what happened we
liberated an American an Arab country by
ending its occupation by foreign troops
our policy worked more generally as well
in that it enhanced American prestige
and influence abroad and made the world
a safer place precisely because
internationally accepted rules of
national conduct had been upheld and
enforced now much more can be said about
the first president Bush but the bottom
line i believe is that he will go down
in history as a successful custodian of
American interests largely because of
his skill in working with other
countries and with international
institutions now there's a certain irony
of his accomplishment in that he made
the American people feel so safe that
they no longer felt they needed a
foreign policy president at all and they
could turn the White House over to a
southern governor untested on the world
stage whose slogan was it's the economy
stupid now as ian has indicated I have a
more than passing interest in and
acquaintance with what happened over the
next eight years but i'm going to
confine myself here to just one
observation and that is that there was
an extremely high degree of continuity
between the foreign policies and the
world views of george herbert walker
bush and william jefferson clinton they
both saw it as their mission to update
and that meant to strengthen and expand
the international architecture that
Franklin Roosevelt Harry Truman Dwight
Eisenhower put in place in the late 40s
and early 50s now I will turn to our
43rd president george walker bush and
here i need to say a word or two in a
personal vain he and i spent four years
together on this campus within walking
distance of this hall we're even
distantly related yet our paths rarely
crossed and I've seen him only once in
the 39 years since we graduated from
Yale that was in a receiving line at the
White House when he and the first lady
held a reception for our class in the
summer of two thousand three just before
the rest of our class boarded a special
Amtrak train up to new haven for our
35th reunion so I feel I owe you this is
kind of a disclaimer because it's been
part of my career as a incurable
Washingtonian to get to know presidents
and in at least one case work for a
president yet my classmate George Walker
Bush is the only one since Lyndon
Johnson whom I have not felt in some
sense I have gotten to know nevertheless
a little over six years ago in January
2001 when mr. Bush was inaugurated I
thought I knew enough about him to
anticipate what sort of president he
would be especially in foreign policy I
could not have been more mistaken he
turned out to be the one thing I would
have never expected a radical the
driving force behind what two of my
colleagues at Brookings evod alder and
Jim Lindsay have called the bush
revolution in American foreign policy
I'll summarize their thesis in terms of
the essential contrast between
the current President Bush and his
father if Bush 41 was an arch
multilateral list Bush 43 has been the
arch unilateral list by that I mean that
he was from the day he took the oath of
office profoundly skeptical
unprecedented Lee skeptical about the
utility of international treaties
international institutions and
international law that was apparent in
the way that he annulled unsigned or
otherwise withdrew from a whole range of
international agreements and mechanisms
the Kyoto Protocol on climate change the
International Criminal Court the
anti-ballistic missile treaty
appropriate that I should be referring
to international law just as Dean co
arrives to make sure that I get the full
list which i'm sure i have not done
however we can come back to it those
examples of unilateralism and numerous
others had two distinguishing features
first they were gratuitous second they
were destructive and not constructive
what I mean in the first case is that
there was no pressing need to shatter or
suspend or block the work of decades and
to tear down or render inoperative
structures that had been put in place it
was not as though that the agreement in
question prevented the administration
from doing anything that it was in a
position actually to do politically
technically or diplomatically moreover
the administration offered no
alternative to what it was saying no to
let's take the example of the Kyoto
Protocol and let's grant that the kyoto
protocol was flawed as surely it was and
is so what were we going to offer that
was better
and the answer quite simply was nothing
President Bush's unilateralism was also
apparent in the way he suspended active
high-level American diplomatic
engagement in to chronically troubled
areas the Middle East and the Korean
Peninsula now in the case of the Korean
Peninsula that's a very timely issue
because we've had some good news in
recent days about a very real genuine
the fragile breakthrough in the talks
there we could have had that
breakthrough five years ago long before
the North Koreans tested a nuclear
weapon but diplomacy was not in fashion
for the first three three-and-a-half
years of the Bush administration why was
that I almost heard it said by members
of the administration and advocates of
their approach that the following
explains why diplomacy was not in
fashion diplomacy is about compromise or
at least about entertaining the
possibility of compromise and this was
an administration that was not in a
compromising mood and this is all before
September 11th before September 11th
President Bush's policies had aroused
significant concern around the world
particularly among our closest friends
and allies who want the United States to
be strong who want the United States to
be a leader their leader and that
concern could be summed up in the
following way the United States was not
only new management that's something
that other countries get used to every
four to eight years it was operating on
a whole new concept of management namely
one that failed to recognize the
difference between being a leader and
being a boss or maybe more to the point
being a bully and then of course came
September 11th
at first that unforgettable day and
looking around this room I can remember
what it meant to a number of you looking
at Gus and looking at Harold ngayon and
Geeta that one of the first things that
happen when we recovered from the shock
and made sure that our loved ones were
okay was that we were deeply gratified
by the massive outpouring of support for
the United States around the world it
was as though everybody in the world was
prepared to let the last nine months be
bygones just about the time that Rick
Levin convened a town meeting in Patel
Chapel thousands upon thousands of
Iranians were turning out in the streets
of Tehran to hold candlelight vigils and
sympathy and support of the United
States but that goodwill evaporated very
quickly when it became apparent that the
effect of 911 on President Bush himself
was to reinforce his aversion to working
through diplomacy international
institutions and alliances and I stress
and alliances because one of the most
telling things that happened after nine
eleven was that NATO for the first time
met in the North Atlantic Council and
invoked the clause and the NATO charter
that basically said attack on one is an
attack on all and offered to help us
make war against the Taliban in
Afghanistan and do so as a joint
alliance operation and we said our
government said no thanks we'll handle
this one ourselves now the story of what
happened next is well known to all of us
we which is to say our government set
about to handle or rock and essentially
the same way and the result of that we
also know very well
was a quick apparent military victory
that turned out to be a political and
military debacle now in the second term
of the Bush administration there has
been some course correction on foreign
policy issues other than Iraq the
administration has made an effort to
repair its relations with key allies
especially in Europe it's reinstated
diplomacy as an acceptable indeed
necessary instrument for advancing some
of our interests especially with regard
to North Korea where as I mentioned
earlier we've seen just in the last
couple of days a rare welcome laudable
but very fragile and tentative
diplomatic success in other respects
however the administration has in the
president's phrase stayed the course or
at least tried to to wit mr. Bush's
attempt to keep that ingenious Doggett
anti diplomat John Bolton in place as
our permanent representative at the
United Nations perhaps mr. Bush is
having second thoughts about the wisdom
of that personnel choice today as he
copes with mr. Bolton hurling criticisms
at him for the North Korea deal I gather
that the President had it was in the
position of having to refute the Bolton
criticisms at his press conference today
and then of course there has been the
president's refusal to accept the key
recommendations of the Baker Hamilton
Iraq study group especially those that
urge that we engage in diplomacy with
all Iraq's neighbors notably including
Syria and Iran but the single most
important respect in which the second
term has been a continuation of the
first is President Bush's personal
conviction that history will vindicate
his decision to take this nation to war
in Iraq in the way that he did which is
to say unilaterally so that in a
nutshell and I realize I'm leaving
plenty of topics out there to come back
to and discussion is my view of what
happened in the six years of the Bush 43
administration what I'd like to do now
is turn to the question of why this
happened and i would suggest there are
three factors first mr. bush came into
office determined to do some positive
things no doubt but also to do something
heavily negative negative in the sense
of repudiating or ripping out root and
branch the legacy of his immediate
predecessor who happens to be the
president that Harold and I and some
others worked for Bill Clinton just to
give you one example of how deep seated
this instinct was on the part of the
president I can remember hearing from
friends of mine mostly civil servants
professional Foreign Service officers
who stayed in the administration after
the departure of the Clinton
administration before as the Bush
administration came in telling me that
they had gone to meetings at the White
House and quickly learned that it was a
taboo to use the word globalization why
because globalization was a Clinton word
and that it was equally discouraged to
say anything about climate change or
global warming why because that was Gore
talk now grudges and score-settling do
not make for sound policy and with a nod
to ball Kennedy and John gatos I would
also say they do not make for sound
grand strategy moreover by setting out
to undo and discredit everything that
his immediate predecessor had done
President Bush was making a radical
break with all of his predecessors and
that means ten of them going back to the
end of World War two five Democrats and
five Republicans including of course his
own father
now the second factor that I would
suggest we need to focus on and that
explains the bush revolution concerns
president bush's particular i would say
peculiar brand of American
exceptionalism now the reason I put it
that way is that all American presidents
and now i'm going back to an earlier
president named george his last name was
Washington all American presidents have
to one degree or another believed in a
form of nationalism that ascribes to the
United States superior qualities
universal values global interests unique
responsibilities and a special special
dispensation maybe even a divine special
dispensation to use its unparalleled and
unprecedented might on behalf of what
its leaders deemed to be right for the
world the president was adhered and i
would say still adheres to an
uncompromising and extreme variant of
American exceptionalism deposits
explicitly that the US has strong enough
both in its hard power and its soft
power to make one set of rules for
itself and different ones for everybody
else and that goes in a way to a third
factor which involves the division of
the world into good and evil as a core
principle for organizing international
system and conducting American foreign
policy and then letting this
geopolitical manak-e ISM substitute for
what I have called earlier a rule-based
international system this has been a
feature of Bush 43 foreign policy from
the beginning but especially after nine
eleven the president you'll recall
proclaimed the war on terror in terms of
an epic epic struggle between us and
evildoers and he demanded that all
countries choose sides either be with us
or against us if you were with us you
got leniency under international law and
the pursuit of
norms and if you're against us there
would be hell to pay and I'll cite just
a couple of examples on both sides of
how this proposition worked in practice
one is Russia President Putin was the
first foreign leader to call President
Bush after the first plane came into the
first tower of the world trade center
and he offered full support for the
American war on terrorism and so he was
considered to be with us very big time
and as a result mr. Bush has cut
president putin lots of slack much too
much slack in my view on his
brutalization of chechnya and his
rollback of political reform and russia
now there's a very different example in
India India is a certifiably good
country it's a new strategic partner
some say even a natural ally of the
United States therefore in the according
to the world view that divides the world
into good and evil India gets civil
nuclear cooperation that in effect
exempts it from the non-proliferation
treaty and that special treatment
creates a moral hazard and a dangerous
precedent since other countries which
are less certifiably good want the same
thing and as a result the NPT the
non-proliferation treaty today is on
artificial life support and fading fast
now on the other side of the Manichean
equation there are those who are against
us and exhibit a there of course is Iran
it sponsors terrorism it does everything
it can to undermine the arab-israeli
peace process and it has a covert
nuclear weapons program indisputable
facts that makes it a certifiably bad
country so we don't negotiate with its
leaders well I ask you what kind of
sense does that make historically or
logically for 40 years we negotiated
with one of the worst of bad regimes the
USSR which had the ability and the
professed will to blow us up
keeping that from happening was
precisely why we did negotiate with that
country and that included a whole series
of American presidents including Ronald
Reagan who declared the Soviet Union to
be the evil empire now all three of
these factors repudiation of the Clinton
legacy which was by transitivity a
repudiation of Bush 41 s legacy as well
extreme exceptionalism and manak-e ism
came together in President Bush's policy
toward Iraq he entered office determined
to be tough towards Saddam Hussein where
he believed Clinton had been soft
dealing decisively with Saddam Hussein
was a kind of twofer it meant getting
rid of an external threat and also
succeeding where his predecessor had
failed second the ultra exceptional lyst
and Bush set out to accomplish that goal
independent of and in defiance of the
rest of the international community and
third the Manichean in mr. bush saw
Saddam as the altar ultimate example of
an evildoer indeed one that he thought
was in league with the sama bin Laden
and that was of course a willful
misperception that led the President to
conflate two very different enemies and
to see regime change in Iraq as a
natural and necessary sequel to regime
change in Afghanistan as a result Iraq
has the potential today of becoming the
most serious consequential foreign
policy blunder in the history of our
Republic now I realize that this is a
fairly bleak assessment of where we are
so let me conclude on a somewhat more
positive note I think that precisely
because Iraq is and is almost
universally recognized to be a policy
disaster one consequence may well be a
national abandonment of the attitudes
that brought it about many of the early
enthusiasts for the Iraq war including
those involved in its planning now see
it's all comic robber and they're saying
so in public as do many members of
on both sides of the aisle many
politicians and mr. Bush's own party
including those who would like to
succeed him are not going to run in 2008
on the promise to uphold his foreign
policy legacy quite the contrary well
there are plenty of differences between
the declared and presumed candidates for
the presidency I'm struck that all of
them Republicans and Democrats with
varying degrees of explicitness are
promising a restoration of what I called
earlier traditional American
internationalism and that's good news at
a time when it's in short supply the
president inaugurated on january
twentieth two thousand nine which is
seven hundred and five days from today
we'll need as much help from as much of
the world as possible that help will
have to come from countries whose
relations with the United States are
strained as well as from an enfeebled
United Nations a NATO that is mired in
Afghanistan and a European Union that
will be nursing grievances against the
United States while trying to patch up
its own internal disputes yet that new
administration will have some advantages
in addition to its honeymoon with
Congress it will also have a grace
period with the world much of the
ill-will toward America that has been
reflected in surveys of international
public opinion is Bush specific foreign
critics will continue to find the united
states often overbearing and sometimes
obnoxious as indeed they did in the pre
bush period but many of them will be
willing to give the next administration
chance to demonstrate a form of
leadership that is easier to follow than
the leadership provided by mr. bush and
the next president whoever he or she is
we'll see and seize that opportunity
anyway such as my hope and if it's borne
out perhaps 30 years from now the bush
presidency that we now have in
Washington will be remembered as a
cautionary
l a consequential and instructive
aberration and the bush legacy that will
be not just remembered but that will be
alive and well will be that of george
herbert walker bush thanks very much and
happy to go to a discussion the before
they opening things up for discussion i
really want to thank strobe for putting
on the table the most consequential
issues that we're all facing today and
starting starting us at least in the
direction of an engaging them
constructively and be and also before
opening this discussion let me say that
when it closes you're all invited to
join us at a reception upstairs perhaps
i could ask the first question though
and take take advantage of the of the
monopoly i have on the microphone just
for a few seconds and then allow you to
field your own questions after that so
this goes to some of the issues you
raised in the last part of your remarks
about what what opportunities and
challenges will be confronting the
administration that takes office in in a
little under two years two years is a
hundred lifetimes in politics as we all
know and many things can and will happen
between now and then but as you
indicated that the most consequential
issue facing us all right now is in
facing the administration and Congress
right now is is what to do in Iraq in
the short term if you look at both the
behavior and the incentives confronting
the administration and the Democrats on
the hill it doesn't seem to be all that
encouraging in that it seems to me that
the the administration has has been
fairly explicit in making it clear
and I think President Bush's Ashley gone
so far is just to say this that they
really are planning to turn this into
the next administration's problem I
think at one press conference not too
long ago professor President Bush
actually said that leaving Iraq all the
sort of endgame Iran will be decided on
by the his successor and what you know
that one one interpretation of the surge
and all of that is really that what
they're trying to do is prevent a
complete meltdown in in Iraq but
basically temporize and turn turn the
problem over to whoever comes next on
the theory that I guess it's like things
are likely to get worse perhaps that's
to on Cheryl and assessment but but it's
mine and I think yurius to say what it
was like whether you agree but then when
you look to the hell things are not
particularly encouraging either in that
it seems like the the Democratic
leadership on both in the house and the
Senate while happy to level criticism
and pass non-binding resolutions is
extremely reluctant perhaps was all the
same reasons that the administration is
reluctant they're extremely reluctant to
take any kind of decisions that would
give them ownership of the results on
the ground in Iraq and that they too i
think would rather things move along
with others apparently responsible at
least through the two thousand eight
election so my question to you is do you
agree with my assessment if so how
should we be thinking about the this
period between now and 2030 but perhaps
even larger challenges than then we're
facing right now you know I sure wish
you ended your question by saying do I
agree with your assessment then I could
have simply said yes
next question a couple thoughts come to
mind I think it's I remember it very
well as I'm sure you do too when the
administration first let it be known
that this was a problem that it was
going to pass on to its successors and
the two people who objected most
strenuously to that notion where Hillary
Clinton and John McCain no fools they
222 points first of all I agree totally
with your assessment both about the
complexity the the damned unas of the
problem that we face now not to mention
the problem which will I sure be worse
when the next president is is
inaugurated and inherits it I also agree
with your critical assessment of the way
both parties are handling this in the
Congress with some exceptions and I
think the essence of the mistake well
maybe it's not even a mistake maybe it's
worse than that of what's going on in
the hill is that so many people are
looking at this issue from the
standpoint of what position should they
take visa the American politics now
American politics matter to American
politicians we understand that and
that's natural but what's really at
issue is how do various proposed
remedies or responses affect Iraqi
politics because it's on the ground in
Iraq that this situation is either going
to get a lot worse or maybe at some
point get better and there is just very
little accommodation of or even much
thinking about that aspect of it which I
guess puts me on the spot of having to
say something that doesn't perpetuate
that mistake and it speaks to the
situation in Iraq I think that we should
start using quotation marks around the
word Iraq and because it's not a state
anymore I said in the course of my
remarks something that I've given some
thought to and that that is this and I
was being actually cautious when I said
it's shaping up to be or as a potential
of being the greatest foreign policy
in the history of our Republic a number
of you particularly those of
approximately my generation might say
hey wait a minute what about Vietnam and
I would argue that this is much worse
than Vietnam for the following reason
having to do with the nature of the
state where we were carrying out the
military action in the case of Vietnam
we were dealing with a naturally unified
state what in westphalian terms would be
called a nation-state only in Southeast
Asia that had been artificially divided
after World War two we carried out a
military operation that didn't work out
and the result of it was that that
artificially divided state was once
again unified and by the way it turned
out that there were not a whole lot of
dominoes in the neighborhood or at least
as many as we had thought in Iraq it's
exactly the opposite we went into what
was an artificially unified state a
construct of primarily British map
makers and statesmen after World War one
a state that have been artificially kept
together including by a 35-year long
totalitarian regime and as a result of
our intervention and our occupation it
is now divided and I am coming
reluctantly painfully to the conclusion
dare I quote Joe Biden I'll be very
careful in doing so Joe bines actually
been quite articulate on this subject
Iraq is already a partitioned entity it
is broken and I think that our policy
has to accept two facts one it's not on
the verge of a civil war it's in the
midst of a civil war and two it is
undergoing partition right now and so
the challenge for American policy is to
help keep that partition from being as
violent as it might be if we continue to
be in denial about that fact now the
real problem here goes to the question
about the surge how do we keep a
partition from going the way that Bosnia
India Pakistan in the late 40s
demonstrated that partitions are likely
to go and the answer would almost
certainly have to be at some point
sooner rather than later with some kind
of international security presence there
to help these populations sort
themselves out because they're sorting
themselves out every day and they're
doing it by increasingly violent means
but how we get the internationals in
there with us to do that I do not know
but I know one thing we can perhaps tamp
the thing down if we were to get around
to exercise its influence and we're
gonna have to appeal to their interests
to do so to help manage the Shiv part of
the equation not a great answer but this
is a situation where there are no great
answers there's a headline on the
Washington outlook section day before
yesterday whenever sunday was that said
victory is not an option management of
the Civil War and the partition of Iraq
means to be the name of the game yes
lady back there I wonder if I could just
make a comment to add a fourth point to
your why about George good and maybe the
consequence afford point would be that
in my understanding Bush was only
outside the country twice once briefly
to Europe and once was dealing with his
father it wants to China so we're also
talking about a certain isolation and
understanding the larger world and if we
could say that the consequence
a sense of consequences of problematic
side it might be the case I'm a student
of east asian studies in East Asian
Studies really came out of the Second
World War the many people the army and
navy language schools came back and set
up East Asian Studies so we might say
even though it might be a little overly
optimistic but in terms of education
that a new understanding of the middle
east of his long the Arab world and
Beyond may as well come out I think your
first point is absolutely valid I was i
I think it should it should be should be
on the list and of course you're making
a you're not just making as it were at
home and employment about the current
president's lack of knowledge of
interest in curiosity about the world
before he assume the presidency you're
making more general point that all and I
would certainly associate myself with
this need need to do much more to
understand are these cultures and I
think that's one of the many reasons why
what Rick and Ian and Ernesto and others
are doing to globalize this university
is is so essential I would also suggest
that there is a fifth factor that might
be mentioned as well and I really left
it out largely for reasons of time but
I'll say it and that is President Bush's
religiosity I certitude can be a
four-letter word and I think that you
know a certain amount of certitude is
necessary in any position that requires
one to be a decider but there is such
thing as excessive certitude and a
refusal to question basic assumptions I
worked for a president who was sometimes
criticized for having the opposite
problem but I can tell you having spent
eight years working for him
that I think it was basically a good
thing and led to better policies the
President Clinton was always willing not
as not only willing sometimes insisting
on saying to those of us who were
working with him now tell me again why
exactly we're putting this guy Aris
feedback in power when we know this
about him and so forth and so on in
Haiti and tell me again how confident we
are that if if we go into into Bosnia
that we're not going to have we're not
going to be right in the middle of a
civil war and what should we be doing if
things go wrong and this president once
he becomes convinced that something is
the right thing doesn't seem to want to
listen to questions of that kind and one
of the reasons and he said it the source
for this is himself is that he has got
instruction from up there yes
at
well the the ease there's an easy in a
hard part the ants the easy part isn't
it much use because it's too late to act
on it indicate the the major exertions
of force that we used in the 90s were
Haiti to restore era steed and Bosnia to
end ethnic cleansing and in Kosovo to
end the genocide in all three cases I
spent literally hundreds of hours in the
Situation Room gaming out what might
happen and a very very small percentage
of our time was spent on the question of
how we went in and and took down the
regime much more time was asking herself
what can go wrong we were spaced it in
every from every possible angle and went
in heavy basically and just tried to be
prepared for the worst eventualities and
that should have happened in Iraq I
actually would respectfully different to
differ with you on how analogous the
Bosnia situation is to Iraq for the
following reason not long after leaving
Yale and after getting a little more
education in England and making him
making a friend over there who got me a
job in government my wife and I lived in
Yugoslavia and this was in Tito time and
we used to travel to Bosnia a lot and
Bosnia was actually a very well
functioning multi-ethnic or more to the
point multi religious community i can
remember traveling through the
countryside from belgrade down to South
dot and abroad Nick where we often went
and and seeing these small villages with
a tiny little minaret and a little
Orthodox Church and a little Catholic
they were doing fine bosnia really went
bad during the Milosevic period it was a
relatively small period of time and they
had had centuries under a combination of
the Ottomans and the hot sports which
were at what as empires go fairly
tolerant they believed in a kind of
subsidiary subsidiarity and devolution
of power and sort of local authority so
they had a kind of political culture
that can be restored there but I'm
afraid that whatever chance there was of
developing that in Iraq decreases every
day when 20 47 more people are blown up
yesterday it was the Shia doing it to
the Sunnis tomorrow what's the soon he's
doing it to the Shia that's just
shattering what was already a very very
weak base to put which is why I think
that maybe Baghdad will have to be
internationalized in some fashion but
the two communities or the three I mean
the Kurds are already out the door read
the piece in The New Yorker by the way
the profile of President talabani if you
want to get some sense of the games that
are being played there he doesn't think
of himself I think long terms the
president of a state called Iraq he's
positioning himself for his next move
against barzani to be the president of
Kurdistan and we just had you know we
shouldn't we shouldn't have wanted that
to come about but now that we have made
put that dynamic and play we have to
deal with it yes
his idea was that this is going to
become a model at a democratic state and
the democracy was spread now is there a
danger of when the swimming the opposite
leg right cascade am I going to contain
that you're absolutely right and I think
you put it brilliantly what was supposed
to be a model for the democratization
and stabilization of the Middle East is
turning out to be a nightmare opposite
and you just have to look around the
periphery to see not only where it's in
danger happening but where the locals
are worried about it happening the
Saudis of course have a lot to be
concerned about for many reasons
including what for them is a Shia
minority that's up in the in the Dharan
region we're of course also a lot of the
a lot of the oil is and spillover is
Iran is now greatly strengthened as a
force in the region a three-star
military officer told me the other day I
mean just come back from us in and rock
that that Iran has now replaced the
United States is the most powerful
country in Iraq and by the way greatly
strengthened in the region another
country that we have to pay a lot of
attention to it seems to me is turkey I
am extremely concerned about both what's
happening inside Turkey what's happening
between Turkey and the European Union
and what's happening between Turkey in
the United States and they all play into
into each other and the Turks are
convinced and I think not without reason
that the United States could be doing
more given its preeminence in northern
Iraq or Kurdistan to stop ekk activity
that's the terrorists or Kurdish terrace
organization that's operating across the
border into into Turkey but I guess one
general point I haven't really answered
your question except to say do what the
Baker Hamilton reports said and get all
these countries too
on the basis of their own self-interest
to figure out ways to stop this thing
from spreading but one of the problems
in addition to the problem of certitude
that I already mentioned and all
administrations have that to some extent
once you get invested in a policy you
have a huge incentive to justify it in
the face of adverse circumstance but the
other thing is that just the day-to-day
management of that deteriorating
situation Iraq is so preoccupying that
the higher levels of the United States
government don't have the time and
energy to think about anything else I've
seen a version of that I can remember
times in the 90s when we were very very
preoccupied with us that of the other
crisis domestic or international and it
was extremely hard to get the attention
at the right level to get something done
but my guess is I'm not my guess my
certainty is from what I hear from
people were in the administration is
that they have four times that
difficulty now just because Iraq is so
bad and getting so much worse day by day
and insofar as they have any energy left
over its to manage the domestic side of
it yes sir
well the warmth was not sustainable
because it was not based either on a
solid personal or a sustainable
political basis President Putin who I
had a chance to work within four of his
capacities is a master of his trade he
knows how to handle the psychology of
dealing with a counterpart or what he
calls a partner but very often somebody
he does not regard as a partner and good
KGB guy that he is he had studied very
carefully not just the facts of
president bush's biography but also
about what appealed to him I remember a
famous story he's not a famous story
it's famous in my brain about Putin
going to Crawford Texas not too long
after 911 and there the issue of the day
was the national missile defense issue
and basically the trashing of the ABM
treaty they had a very small private
meeting and in the midst of it they
would go getting along quite well with
each other and Putin started opening his
shirt you know like this and that was a
little strange this was a button mine
needs to be closed here and people were
very few people in the room wondered
what is this all about he reached into a
shirt pulled out a crucifix and he said
George the reason you and I do so well
together is that we're both believers
okay there haven't been crucifix moments
for some time now and of course set the
Kunda conference in Munich just a few
days ago President Putin be gave a
speech that made mine look very mild
indeed in criticizing Bush unilateralism
and by the way people who were in berk
Linda
at that conference tell me that there
was a lot of there a lot of nodding
heads around the room that didn't get a
whole lot of coverage in the play that
fat back here now Putin is that so Putin
was making some points that resonated in
the room there was also a feeling that
Putin was the least legitimate
imaginable person to be making those
points given Russia's own behavior I
think that the the next president is
going to have to take a whole new look
at Russia and deal with Russia as it
continues probably for a number of years
as long as oil prices are high to labor
under the illusion that there's such a
thing as an energy superpower and Russia
is going to have to be reminded that it
was integrated into these international
institutions over the past decade and a
half on the premise that it was going to
play by our rules and that means not the
United States's rules goes back to that
point again but the international
community's rules and right now Russia
is operating on the premise that it's so
powerful and its neighbors need its oil
and gas so much that yes it's going to
be part of the global economy but the
global community's going to have to play
is going to have to accept it on its own
terms and that's a debate that's going
to have to be worked out and I think the
international community can as it were
win because the essence of being a
energy superpower is going to prove very
ephemeral over time and eventually the
Russians are going to have to institute
rule of law at home recognize rule
abroad or they're not going to be able
to become a modern country yes sir mr.
well it's a very good question and I can
offer a thought with a bit more
confidence with regard to Iran and with
regard to Syria because even though I
haven't been in Iran for some time I
followed it more closely I also think
that Iran of the two is probably more
important there has been a tendency
particularly in the part of the
administration in the way it talks about
Iran to depict it as a monolithic member
of the axis of evil a just thoroughly
rogue state and actually I suspect their
people in the room who know around a lot
better than I do but my impression is
that it is much more complicated in a
positive way than that Iran has got
multiple sources of power and nexuses of
identity of what it's all about you've
got the clerical establishment which is
both troublemaking and obviously ultra
conservative and theocratic you've got
bak Medina shod who is everything that
President Bush says he is and worse but
you also have a democracy at least to
some extent and it's interesting that
off Medina jods chain has been yanked in
two directions the ayatollahs are trying
to rein him in and the electorate and
you know when was the last time we
thought about what the electric
electorate was telling the Saudi
monarchy to do has sent strong signal
that Ahmadinejad that they wished that
dr. Medina God would get off this tear
about you no denying the Holocaust and
making the rest of the world mad and
concentrate on why he was mayor of Wye
was a successful mayor of Tehran why was
elected president which is basically
about fixing potholes do something for
us you know govern the country decently
people who know Iran very well say that
the youth there is hot you know into the
internet and just champing at the bit to
see these old guys go on and I think
over time if we could if we could engage
with Iran
or I know this is sort of a classic
appeal but I really do believe it if we
could engage with Iran more we could
find ways of encouraging those forces in
Iran that will if permitted to do so
transform it into a more normal country
yes sir
well the israel-palestinian conflict is
of course a seemingly insoluble
permanent factor in the greater greater
Middle East I say seemingly there have
been moments certainly at the end of the
90s when it looked like had there been
braver wiser leadership especially on
the Palestinian side real progress could
have been made I think it was one of the
great tragedies of history that Yasser
Arafat lived as long as he did and that
he was the fundamentally incurably
rejectionist leader of the Palestinians
when particularly Prime Minister Barack
was prepared to make the deal that he
was so there have been opportunities in
the past there may be opportunities in
the future not anytime soon but I would
strongly argue against the proposition
that the impacted festering nature of
the arab-israeli conflict as a major
factor with regard to what's happening
in Iraq or for that matter what's
happening in Saudi Arabia or for that
matter in Fanning the flames of al-qaeda
terrorism it's a it's a convenient
excuse it's a kind of hate flag to wave
from time to time but I'm going to
strike a another rather somber note
about the standing of our own country
and our own president right now we have
a very very fine scholar at Brookings
when we share with University of
Maryland name should we tell ha me and
Shibley is releasing this week data
based on very extensive sophisticated
public opinion polling in in much of the
Arab world and one of the questions that
they pose is which figure do least like
or most hate maybe the way that it's
that it's put and the you know the
leading figure has always been whoever
the Prime Minister of Israel is
and and particularly when the Prime
Minister of Israel's name was Sharon in
these latest polls george w bush's
negatives are larger than the negatives
of Prime Minister Olmert and general
Sharon put together now what the
implications of that are for Middle East
diplomacy I think are both or are
obvious in the near term and it's really
almost a moot point because I don't
think the administration is going to
have the time or the political will to
really really speaks process the
implications for the next president
president Romney President Obama other
names come to mind I are positive and it
goes back to a point that I made in my
remarked because so much of the anger of
the world is concentrated on this
administration on this president I think
there's going to be a huge sense of
relief not universal but a very very
widespread sense of relief and a
willingness to help the United States
get its act back together including and
by in an early test of it will be
whether the next administration is
prepared to re-engage in the middle east
on the arab-israeli conflict Carol
I I think first of all I hope that
anybody contemplating having that job
will ask that question a lot of people
other than me or maybe in addition to be
starting real soon and not wait until
then that's an obvious but I mean that
is more of a wisecrack I think that the
the nation and the planet face to
existential threats and when I say
existential threats I mean things that
threaten our survival as a civilization
and one eye is climate change and the
other is a new wave of nuclear
proliferation they could bring true the
nightmare John Kennedy expressed back in
1961 now what to do about that go back
to treaties that have been allowed to
languish or that have been shredded re
enter negotiations in the first instance
with the Russian Federation on
significant near-term reductions in
strategic offensive weapons return to
the table and the issue of how to manage
defenses which is to say resurrect in
spirit and perhaps in letter the ABM
treaty particularly now that china is in
the a SAT game the satellite killing
game do we want that game to go try it
triangular on top of an offensive
build-up so that for sure with regard to
the non-proliferation treaty figure out
a way starting with India now that we're
stuck with and over the hump of the
civil nuclear deal to try to get India
to sign up to a universal ban on the
production of fissile material and then
use the fact that India has done that to
get Pakistan to do what Pakistan always
seems to do which is follow Indian
either the right direction of the wrong
and I would also say on the on the NPT
that there is still time I think to get
Iran to stop short of the red line of
having a testable deployable nuclear
weapon whether we have a year and a half
or two years to get that done is a big
question and Harold I will tell you that
until elastico till four days ago I did
not think we had that opportunity with
regard to North Korea I've read
everything and I have no Chris Hill
extremely well I've been in touch with
him since this breakthrough he is a he
is the most capable of most cautious of
diplomats and his his optimism about
this deal is extremely carefully
qualified but I do think that there may
be more opportunity with regard to North
Korea but it's going to require
negotiating with those countries and
with Iran and what I I guarantee you
you're going to see editorials and you
hope I certainly hope you're going to
see editorials and op-ed page pieces and
I hope statements from both Republicans
and Democrats saying mr. president
follow the logic of what you've done
with regard to North Korea and apply it
to Iran you know going back to ends
opening question if we're going to enter
bring Iran in a meaningful way into some
kind of regional conf AB on the future
of Iraq we have to know that they're
going to come with a price in mind that
they're going to want us to pay and one
reason that the registration doesn't
want to negotiate with Iran is because
they know the coinage in which they're
going to want to be paid and it's going
to be concessions and the issue of
enrichment and ask for a degree of
enrichment that they are technically
allowed under the NPT and that is a
really tough issue it's a tough issue
for us and it's a tough issue for the
Israelis and very legitimately but it's
a negotiation is going to have to be had
and the sooner we'll start at the more
chances there are of it succeeding so
those are the three big steps i would
say this is after restoring habeas
corpus and closing down
on several other things you virtually to
work into something I'm writing yes that
lady right there no I really do not
think that President Bush was dependent
on Prime Minister Blair support to go
into Iraq I think he was prepared to do
it alone and would have done it alone
and he's virtually said as much the you
this is not a what if question but a why
question why did Prime Minister Blair
take the position that he did and I I
would explain it with at least three
points one is I think Prime Minister
Blair who I thought in many ways was the
most eloquent and persuasive advocate
for military intervention in Iraq
genuinely believed as I believe that the
international community should use force
to change or force changes in a regime
that is grossly and systematically
abusing civilized norms and those of the
international community he believes in
that very much second he attached and
still attaches huge importance in the
special relationship with the United
States and did not want a breach between
the United States and the UK to damage
that relationship in third he believed
mistakenly that if he was part if he was
joined at the hip with george w bush he
might be able to have some modifying or
moderating influence over him as the
policy unfolded and Prime Minister Blair
has paid a terrible price for that
trifecta of of calculations and it's too
bad but
there we are gossip it's only one more
question you should definitely get it I
am I think the oil factor is a natural
presumption particularly when the
president united states is a Texas Texan
with a lot of oil in his background but
I honestly don't think it loomed very
large I'll share with the group and then
we can go have a drink a an anecdote I
think it was on the twentieth of
december two thousand the day that the
Supreme Court decided in favor of
essentially president bush's election
that is to stop the recount President
Bush President Clinton and governor Bush
had a private meeting and in that
private meeting President Clinton talked
will astonish you here at some length
with a whole bunch of ideas about the
issues that he was going to be passing
on to President Bush President Elect
Bush as he could then call him and you
know it I think first on the list Lord
if neither Middle East was on it dealing
with India was on it
terrorism was very high up on the list
there were about seven or eight issues
and I think last on his list was dealing
with the ongoing problem of Saddam
Hussein and president bush was fidgeting
a bit was real interested in hearing
this list and Clinton picked up on that
he said you know George having listened
to you and will paid a lot of attention
which have said during the campaign my
sense is that the really the only two
foreign policy issues that you care
about a lot our national missile defense
Star Wars and doing something about
Saddam Hussein and Bush locked his eyes
on Clinton's and said that's exactly
right those are my two priorities and I
do not think that in the case of dealing
with Saddam Hussein straits of hormuz
and oil had anywhere near as much to do
with his thinking as a combination of
its a complex combination Gus two points
that had to do with his own father and
he's one of which he's acknowledged on
several occasions that is the present
president has Saddam Hussein tried to
kill us and that really mattered him but
the other factor was that his father
left Saddam in place after the first
Gulf War and he President Bush was
looking for some way to distinguish
himself let's put it more neutrally
distinguish himself from his father and
take care of a piece of unfinished
business not just from the Clinton
administration but from the first Bush
administration and that was in his head
and there was a lot of planning that
went on during those first nine months
and then when 911 happened the logical
thing to do would have been to say all
right now how much does a rock and
Saddam Hussein have to do with this
al-qaeda thing and in global terrorism
and the answer is not much but that
wasn't the answer they came up with the
answer they came up with was it has
everything to do with it and they
conflated the two
so those I think were the two real
things that drove them and they also
sense all of a sudden President Bush
found himself you know you could see it
in his body English when he grabbed the
bullhorn at Ground Zero and all of a
sudden you know he really had the bit in
his teeth and it was it was a wartime
president and he saw that war in terms
of two stages and maybe more than two
stages but take care of Afghanistan
Taliban and then go after and go after
Saddam and in so doing take care of that
unfinished business that my dad left me
well stroke thank you very much indeed
you certainly have have lived up to
every expectation we had that
you